[Musica]
bene buonasera e partiamo subito dal
titolo l'eroismo delle piccole cose
talmente piccole da essere quasi
invisibile
io oggi vi parlerò di educazione perché
questa è la mia professione gli parlerò
anche dal pedagogista perché è appunto
il campo di studi nei quali da anni mi
impegno con i risultati che spero essere
degni di questo grandissimo compito di
questa grande sfida quella
dell'educazione che ci tocca tutti non
solo appunto gli educatori pedagogisti
professionisti ma genitori ma
divulgatori ma scienziati artisti
politici giornalisti
l'educazione e la formazione mi viene da
dire è un compito che ci tocca è un
impegno di una responsabilità condivisa
di tutti coloro che lavorano vivono a
mano all'interno della società e
l'eroismo delle piccole cose mi ha
portato a come dire pensare a tutte
quante quelle piccole cose che
intervengono nella nostra vita nella
nostra esistenza ci rendono quello che
siamo quelle piccole cose che ci formano
e ci educano io sono qui il professore
di pedagogia ma io sono qui come padre
di porto questa identità mi porto un
identità che culturale che istituzionale
che un identità di genere porto con me
tante identità che tra loro come dire
vivono e convivono anche inquietamente
ma tutte quante la maggior parte
invisibili la maggior parte
inconsapevoli la maggior parte non
gestita da me di fatto mi come dire
colorano ogni singola parola ciascuno di
noi dice io porto in esempio ma
naturalmente questo vale per tutti
quanti noi
e dunque per affrontare la tematica
dell'invisibilità mi son chiesto da dove
cominciare
e come dire come sempre bisogna
cominciare dall'inizio e quindi della
definizione più semplice più generali
che cos'è l'educazione come funziona
educazione no l'educazione funziona e
lavora nella vita di ciascuno di noi
ecco cos'è la vita la vita e la
consapevolezza che cosa ci fa sentire
vivi
beh ci fa sentire vivi la consapevolezza
che noi
siamo chi eravamo ieri e non siamo
neanche quelli che pensiamo di poter
essere domani la vita fondamentalmente
la presa di consapevolezza di questa
metamorfosi di questa trasformazione la
vita è trasformazione trasformazione
anche nella stessa definizione c'è il
termine di formazione ed è un cammino
che ci accompagna dal primo vagito fino
all'ultimo respiro che potremo esalare e
anche oltre l'ultimo respiro e anche
prima del primo vagito per motivi che
magari non staremo poi ad approfondire
ma c'è tutto un immaginario che si
accompagna le nostre vite prima di
nascere e dopo anche la morte che ci
mantengono vivi all'interno della
comunità e dei ricordi e non soltanto
dunque per tutta la vita ma anche in
tutti i contesti nei quali viviamo noi
siamo ci formiamo non soltanto a scuola
non soltanto all'università ma ci
formiamo sul posto di lavoro ci formiamo
nelle relazioni interpersonali ci
formiamo con il gruppo dei pari c'è una
diffusività dell'azione formativa che ci
rende tutti ciascuno di noi responsabili
e questo è tanto più importante se noi
pensiamo alla formazione dei formatori
agli educatori che poi in strada o con
le situazioni e le situazioni di
marginalità operano che devono imparare
ad almeno questa qua
come dire una proposta non devono
imparare la centralità che ha la loro
posizione
il loro essere individui non come monadi
no ma come parte di sistemi che si
ampliano e si spandono tanto
nell'infinitamente piccolo
all'infinitamente piccolo quanto
nell'infinitamente grande tanto dal
microscopico il microsistema che qui è
rappresentato dalla fotografia di un
atomo quanto al macro sistema che dalla
galassia
noi siamo dei messo sistemi dei sistemi
che si trovano nel mezzo siamo uomini
che entrano in relazione con dimensioni
invisibili micro che sono quelle
atomiche sono quelle cellulari sono
quelle fisiologiche ma sono anche quelle
psicologiche parte della nostra identità
ma anche con i sistemi macro quindi la
cultura la società il pianeta cosmo noi
siamo sistemi in relazione con altri
sistemi e questi altri sistemi che sono
molto spesso invisibili perché troppo
piccole o troppo grandi
non mancano però di avere un peso sulla
nostra vita nulla ci resta indifferente
nulla ci lascia in toccati ma tutte
quante queste dimensioni di volta in
volta come dire partecipano anno la
nostra possibilità di determinarsi molto
spesso in maniera invisibile molto
spesso in maniera inconsapevole
raramente rientrando nell'orbita di
quello che noi possiamo leggere del
mondo e possiamo dunque predire e
gestire del mondo
questa situazione trova come dire un
principio come dicevo fondamentale
dell'azione educativa e ci si potrebbe
aspettare infatti che grandi pedagogisti
la abbiano interpretato grandi filosofi
o magari anche grandi fisici no invece
la parola più coerente e quella più
efficace per esprimere questo concetto
io personalmente l'ho trovata in una
poesia di machado poi machado che un
grande autore ripreso tante volte da
moreno e del quale io vi leggerò
soltanto alcuni passaggi fondamentali
alcuni versi machado ci racconta nella
figura del viandante che stigmatizza con
una con delle parole meravigliose con
delle parole di assoluto efficace
viandante sono le tue impronte il
cammino e niente più viandante non c'è
cammino il cammino si fa andando andando
si fa il cammino e nel rivolgere lo
sguardo è quel sentiero che non si
tornerà mai più a rifare o quantomeno
non si potrà mai rifare nella stessa
maniera di una prima volta
questa figura è questa logica del
viandante la logica dell'educazione la
nel nell'evento educativo non quando noi
pensiamo
riteniamo di poter guidare la strada
allora ci troviamo di fronte
all'imprevisto dal punto di vista della
scienza dell'educazione noi abbiamo
rinunciato a trovare delle leggi
assoluti dei protocolli delle norme che
possano in maniera lineare dirci che è
una determinata azione a consegue un
effetto b ma il cammino della formazione
dell'uomo perché l'educazione è soltanto
questo formazione dell'uomo e della
donna e promozione della sua
generatività in questo cammino noi
dobbiamo restare estremamente sensibili
a tutte quelle parti che non rientrano
nella legge che non rientrano nella
norma e questo lo so io tra virgolette
dell'educatore lo sanno gli educatori ma
lo sanno anche i genitori lo sanno anche
gli imprenditori lo sa chiunque di noi
nella nostra vita la storia va avanti
passo dopo passo va avanti in momento
per momento e in ogni momento in ogni
passaggio diventa estremamente
importante riuscire a cogliere quei
tanti segnali che il mondo intero ci
manda che che ci sta a fianco ci manda e
in questa maniera comprendere che di
fatto noi sistema di sistemi sono presi
in una rete i cui legami ci connettono
tutti all'interno o all'inter come dire
nel
nell'ampio orizzonte che è dato dai
confini del nostro stesso mondo si parla
in questo contesto in questa in questo
tempo in maniera molto spesso ridondante
dell'esistenza di una comunità di
destino ma attenzione quando si parla di
comunità di destino ossia della
rilevanza delle azioni pensati in
termini glocali ossia azioni fatte
localmente ma che guardino in
prospettiva alla dimensione planetaria
noi non stiamo parlando di nient'altro
se non dell'intuizione che nel formarsi
e nell'agire dell'uomo determinante
questa rete che ci connette tutti quanti
perché di fatto questo comporta che
ciascuno di noi acquisisca la
responsabilità delle sue azioni nell'hic
et nunc restando consapevole che come un
sesso un sasso lanciato in uno stagno
per cerchi concentrici la nostra azione
può finire per creare effetti che
coprono tutta quanta la superficie dello
stagno non molto differentemente da
quello che in maniera poetica alcuni
metereologi hanno definito l'effetto
farfalla questa condizione di comunità
di destino
no per questa rete costituita per questa
rete così intensa per questa tanta
invisibilità che interviene nella nostra
vita ci apre alla presa di
consapevolezza che noi non possiamo
gestire il mondo lo possiamo orientare
ma non lo possiamo predeterminare la
nostra relazione col mondo e una
relazione sempre innovativa sempre
creativa noi siamo destinati a errare
siamo destinati a sbagliare ma siamo
parimenti destinati a pagare su questo
mondo come ci diceva il viandante il
viandante ha una percezione di sé su una
terra su un suolo e decide di mettere il
passo in questo senso il suo passo è una
continua sfida una continua sfida per
realizzare quel sentiero che sulla terra
non c'è che sarà la sua vita che è il
suo progetto che sono i suoi sogni che
sono i suoi desideri che la sua capacità
di corrispondere a questa rete
noi dobbiamo convivere con l'errore e
non lo possiamo eliminare delle nostre
vite dobbiamo imparare ad errare perché
imparare ad errare può significare
gestire l'errore è come lo facciamo
quale grande insegnamento ci può
derivare la specie umana da sempre
convive con l'errore da sempre ha
trovato inventato e costruito strategie
per gestire l'errore per fare un esempio
banale il sapere la scienza ma insieme
al sapere alla scienza per gestire e
mettere ordine creare un frammento di
ordine nel mondo e nella relazione col
mondo che così caotica e così
indeterminata insieme a questo sapere
c'è anche la poesia c'è anche l'arte c'è
anche la letteratura c'è persino
l'empatia come dispositivo ormai
sappiamo genetico per una
predisposizione genetica dell'uomo a
essere empatico con i co specifici sono
tante strategie e sono tutte valide e
devono essere tutte percorse perché il
problema non è quello di coltivare
sapere che limited errore dal punto di
vista educativo l'errore è confondere
che quella logica sia l'unica possibile
che una logica che la logica della
scienza sia l'unico sguardo che noi
possiamo avere sul mondo o che lo sia la
logica della poesia o la logica
dell'economia o la logica della politica
e via dicendo no sono tutti sguardi che
rendono porzioni di invisibilità del
mondo parzialmente visibili e noi
dovremmo come dire in un certo qual modo
riuscire attraverso questi saperi a
coltivarli tutte non confondendo ripeto
questo è l'insegnamento o comunque il
principio di cui si dovrebbe tener conto
non confondendo mai una logica con la
logica e questo cosa significa vuol dire
dunque restare aperti appunto a tutte
quante quelle dimensioni che
immediatamente non ci sono presenti che
non sono per noi immediatamente chiare
perché per portare degli esempi concreti
e normale essere dei genitori
preoccupati quello che non è normale è
che un genitore preoccupato
ignorando l'invisibilità del mondo del
bambino diventi un progetto un genitore
iperprotettivo che quindi nega il mondo
invisibile del bambino riducendo la sua
unica logica di protezione quello che
non deve accadere che un educatore
proteiforme progettuale diventi un
burocrate diventi un programmatore
ignorando l'invisibilità che gli altri
saperi li possono dare in riferimento al
mondo
del proprio soggetto informazione o di
se stesso contesto nel quale si pratica
la formazione ma anche in riferimento
alla nostra stessa vita
ciò che dovremmo tener conto ad esempio
e come molto spesso nelle nostre vite
quella luce che ha illuminato il nostro
sguardo di stupore e di meraviglia il
tau mazen greco che era ciò che come
dire e avveniva prima c'era prima della
possibilità di definire il sapere beh
col tempo si sia molto spesso spento e
ci abbia visto un piccione visto
protagonisti di una trasformazione che
ci ha portato ad essere degli adulti
inquadrati ben collocate all'interno di
una determinata dimensione di una
determinata rappresentazione no il
principio ecco educativo e quello invece
di porre attenzione a queste dimensioni
invisibile coltivarle coltivare
l'invisibilità perché coltivare
l'invisibilità vuol dire coltivare la
sensibilità nei confronti di un mondo
che grazie al cielo ci vedrà sempre
sconfitti nella misura in cui noi
imposteremo la nostra vita come ricerca
dell'ordine completo non si da quando
avremo l'ordine completo noi avremo
finito di vivere
avremo un mondo che tutto sommato non ci
meraviglia più non ci sorprende più e
dunque anche per arrivare un attimo al
termine 2 come dire indicazioni d'uso
due consigli d'uso per noi stessi e per
le persone con le quali non entriamo in
relazione che si sia insegnanti cece
educatore o si sia genitori o si sia
datore di lavoro colleghi di lavoro o
semplicemente amici
il primo bisogna riuscire a coltivare la
competenza del saper leggere i segnali e
plurali segnali tanti segnali che il
mondo ci manda
touring
padre dell'intelligenza artificiale a
metà degli anni cinquanta in un suo
testo scrisse come lo spostamento di un
miliardesimo di millimetro di un
elettrone può fare la differenza un anno
dopo
tra la vita e la morte di una persona di
fronte a una valanga
riuscire a riconoscere i segnali in
questo caso sarebbe questo miliardesimo
di millimetro riuscire a riconoscere
questi segni ci permette di avere una
maggiore come dire consapevolezza di
quello che c'è intorno tanti più
linguaggi noi impariamo a conoscere
impariamo a leggere tanto più segnali
noi impariamo a leggere tanto più avremo
la possibilità di agire in maniera
efficace nei confronti del mondo che ci
circonda che è un mondo col quale noi
siamo in una relazione
potremmo definire una danza
trasformativa co evolutiva sia del
soggetto che del mondo e la seconda
avvertenza di natura pedagogica
particolarmente importante è quella di
fare attenzione a coltivare l'anti
fragilità questo è un termine più
recente e noi siamo abituati a sentir
parlare tanto mai come in questo periodo
tra l'altro di resilienza
ma in questo periodo in cui la località
come caratteristica dell'azione si è
mostrata nelle grandi crisi economiche
nelle grandi crisi sanitarie dicendo
questa parola anti fragilità è stata
sdoganata più o meno nel 2012 e 2013 da
uno studioso un economista che si chiama
taleb no
nasser nicholas taleb è l'anti fragilità
e quella caratteristica per cui una
determinata realtà a differenza della
reggina realtà resiliente di un'altra
realtà resiliente anziché una volta
subito e subito un trauma tornare come
dire affrontare il trauma e tornare
nella posizione o nella condizione
iniziale
beh noi invece se anti fragile utilizza
quel trauma utilizza quel danno per
trasformarsi in qualcosa di migliore
quindi per migliorarsi per cambiare
identità per modificarsi diventare
qualcosa di altro qualcosa di più
efficace nel processo di continuo
adattamento al mondo una strada
asfaltata che subisce un trauma diventa
l'occasione per un seme infinitamente
piccolo un quasi invisibile per trovare
un terreno fertile dar vita a qualcosa
di nuovo
questo è il senso che ho voluto dare
all'intervento trezza per leggeri
segnali e coltivare l'anti fragilità si
dà la possibilità se noi siamo in grado
ripeto da educatori perché il ruolo e
questo io sono qui da pedagogista allora
forse sarebbe in grado di far sì che
tanti piccoli segnali tante piccole
realtà quasi visibili possano attecchire
nei nostri giovani permettendogli di
diventare di sognare di realizzare
qualcosa che ancora meravigliosamente
non si è manifestato l'eroismo delle
piccole cose in fondo è la risposta
ingenua da un punto di vista educativo
quasi ingenuo che può sembrare ingenuo
di un colore di un ottimismo che
l'educatore non può non avere chiunque
di voi abbia un ruolo educativo
necessariamente deve essere ottimista
perché si deve scommettere sul fatto che
il mondo possa essere un luogo migliore
è che di fatto ciascun soggetto possa
coltivare la sua generatività diventando
ciò che è ossia un uomo e una donna
votati alla ricerca del proprio
benessere grazie
[Applauso]